Chris waters here today the co-creator
of the original xbox ed freeze has laid
out a bunch of ways that he thinks the
xbox one can gain an edge in the console
war and surprise surprise they're all
pretty obvious freezes the former vice
president of game publishing at
Microsoft and was a co-founder of the
Xbox project helping Microsoft break
into the game console business during an
AMA on ya bleah he said they need better
exclusive games than the ps4 duh they
need to be more open to indie developers
duh they need to adopt free-to-play
gaming more aggressively aha they need
to continue to move Xbox Live forward as
a leading online service seriously they
need to show people why they included
the new kinect on every machine by
demonstrating a compelling use for it do
they yes freeze also gave his opinion on
the Virtual Reality craze that has been
making headlines due to Facebook
purchasing oculus for two billion and
Sony's announcement of their own VR
headset project Morpheus priests said
I'm not sure what Microsoft is up to
these days I hear rumors about all kinds
of cool stuff but will it make it to
market after watching 3d TV fail so
spectacularly the last few years I'm a
bit of a skeptic about VR at least for
the broad consumer market but for
hardcore gamers who knows maybe it will
work and bring some amazing new
experiences I am skeptical that general
users are going to be strapping this
thing onto their faces anytime soon
people seem to have conflicting views on
the future vr especially here at the
gamespot offices but I think we can all
agree that the xbox one would only be
helped by better games a flourishing
indie scene and a reason to own and plug
in that connect leave your comments
below thanks for watching